bonsoir à tous ses points de vue ravi de
vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
émission quotidienne on a choisi pour
vous aujourd'hui quatre thèmes on espère
qu'ils vont vous intéresser et selon que
ton doute pas il y aura des points de
vue différents là dessus nous allons
parler d' eric piolle c'est le maire de
grenoble il est un il est écologiste et
il s'est déclaré solidaire des migrants
jusqu'à accepter d'être condamné pour
cela il a par ailleurs décorée de la
médaille de sa ville un défenseur des
migrants faut-il le soutenir faut-il le
condamnez vous nous le dire et nous
parlerons c'est de la dépense publique
le gouvernement a réuni un séminaire
aujourd'hui pour essayer de trouver
juste un peu d'argent 100 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2022 d'économie d'argent
public pour l'instant on ne voit pas
grand chose venir les économies c'est
pour quand nous parlerons de laïcité
puisque jean michel blanquer le ministre
de l'éducation nationale vient de faire
paraître un nouveau guide de la laïcité
qui se trouve être plutôt plus sévère ou
plus strictes que le précédent est-ce
que c'est trop vous nous donnerez votre
point de vue et puis nous parlerons des
droits du foot qui atteindre des
montants peut être délirant plus d'un
milliard d'euros par an pour les droits
de la ligue 1 c'est un opérateur
espagnol totalement inconnu en france
qui vient de remporter le marché tout ça
est il bien raisonnable
vous nous le dira et bonsoir l'yonne de
montjoux vous êtes grand reporter au
figaro magazine on est ravi de vous
retrouver tout comme reda didi bonsoir
qui n'est pas grand reporter au figaro
magazine mais qu'on est aussi ravi de
retrouver
vous êtes expert associé à la fondation
jean jaurès vous êtes le fondateur du
think tank graines de france et vous
avez été conseiller du ministre
socialiste de la ville patrick kanner
bonsoir brice couturier il faut être sur
la liste à france culture on peut vous
retrouvez du lundi au vendredi pour le
tour du monde des idées c'est à 11h53 et
sinon il ya d'excellents podcast vous
êtes aussi l'auteur de macron le
président philosophe publié aux édition
de l'observatoire et benoît du moulin
est avec nous aussi bonsoir vous êtes
rédacteur en chef adjoint de l'un
correct ce qui est à la fois un site
internet et un magazine
on va dire où s'expriment toutes les
sensibilités de la droite vous êtes
aussi
le coauteur avec charles beigbeder de
charnellement de france ouvrage paru aux
éditions pierre guillaume deux roues
nous commençons donc par parler des
migrants il ya plusieurs événements
d'actualité
sur ce sujet je le disais eric piolle le
maire de grenoble
europe ecologie les verts a envoyé un
tweet au procureur de la république en
disant je suis solidaire des migrants et
puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est un délit
j'accepte d'être condamné il a par
ailleurs décorée
le défenseur des migrants cédric héroux
de la médaille de la ville de grenoble
c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de notre
question twitter soutenez-vous ou non la
décision du maire de grenoble de décor
et cédric héroux et puis aujourd'hui a
été jugé après plusieurs renvois de son
procès une militante d'amnesty
international elle s'appelle martin
landry et elle est jugée pour avoir
facilité l'entrée de deux jeunes
migrants sur le territoire français
écoutez ce que disait de l'action de
cette femme sylvie brigaud villa c'est
la directrice générale d'amnesty
international france
martin les a prises en charge a mené à
la paf a mené à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance de manière à ce qu'ils soient
protégés
voilà ce que martin a fait et voilà ce
qu'on me reproche aujourd'hui
et voilà ce qu'on veut c'est aujourd'hui
en france de criminaliser précisément
les personnes qui apportent leur aide
pour que les droits des personnes qui
sont migrants et réfugiés en france soit
respectée et simplement pour qu'on
puisse accueillir décemment
ces personnes qui cherchent refuge chez
nous puisque tourner d'un côté il ya la
loi plus sévère maintenant même si elle
n'est pas encore complètement en place
concernant le là que des migrants france
et de l'autre côté de cet élan de
solidarité
et entre les deux il ya le citoyen qui
doit se prononcer là dessus qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous il ya surtout un
maire eric piolle qui est d'europe
écologie les verts et moi je me souviens
quand même que europe écologie les verts
c'était un des groupes importants de
l'assemblée nationale dans la dernière
législature et qu'aujourd'hui il n'en
reste aucun cas vous allez dire une
méchanceté large l'attendait je constate
aussi que cécile duflot qui était
ministre de
les territoires il faisait emmanuel
coste qui était ministre du logement ont
trouvé du travail hors de la politique
difficilement du reste dans le cadre de
d'emmanuel coste avait dû monter un
cabinet de conseil en immobilier donc le
vieux rêve des socialistes de substituer
au parti communiste français d'autrefois
un nouvel allié qui était manifestement
très en pointe il ya encore cinq ou six
ans est totalement foiré est ce que ça
veut dire que la position des écoles
aujourd'hui elle ne représente plus rien
dans la population puisque son parti ne
représente plus rien lâcher ça vaudra
raisonnement mon raisonnement c'est
qu'un officier municipal officier de
police qui est un maire ne doit pas
contrevenir à la loi
or là il à réquisitionner des logements
soit disant vacants pour y loger des
migrants il n'est absolument pas à faire
moi si vous les jeux j'aurais tendance à
renvoyer dos à dos les identitaires qui
croient jouer les crs à nos frontières
et qui refoulent les migrants venus
d'italie et des gens comme ce maire qui
lui va chercher à face soutien des gens
qui vont été chercher des gens refoulés
de france en italie pour les ramener
chez nous c'est lui qui va payer pour
l'éducation la santé la formation
l'hébergement de ces gens si si les
hébergent
c'est aux frais de la municipalité de
grenoble j'espère que ce n'est pas aux
frais donc le préfet qu'il a remis
sérieusement dans les rails a bien fait
oui c'est pas le rôle d'un maire si
c'est pour relancer europe ecologie les
verts franchement c'est mal barré
reda didi l'acte
l'acte et les propos contenus le maire
de le maire eric piolle sont
condamnables la loi moi j'ai jamais été
un fervent partisan de la désobéissance
civile je pense que quand on est maire
quand on est responsable tout court
d'ailleurs on a forcé d'exemplarité il
faut montrer l'exemple
à partir de là on se doit de respecter
la loi on voit bien que ça ça a été
monté comme un coup de communication
même si je pense qu'il ya derrière un
coup d'oeil à voir d'ailleurs un couteau
et sincère parce que c'est comme ça
qu'il explique lui aussi dans dans son
interview fleuve
sas a un mérite cette sortie c'est de
remettre cette question en débat alors
que d'autres actes ont alimenté
l'actualité ces derniers temps et ça met
le doigt sur une question assez assez
assez importante pour moi c'est que je
pense que la loi asile l'immigration qui
a été voté à l'assemblée nationale n'a
pas été assez construite avec les
organisations qui connaissent
qui connaissent le sujet voilà même
parfois construite contre elle
puisqu'elle se plaignent d'un tex trop
répressif elles se plaignent attaque
trop répressive se plaignent surtout de
ne pas avoir été consultés en amont pour
co-construire ce texte
ce texte-là on viendra sur une tonne de
thématiques qui est notamment le déficit
le déficit français comment comment
comment ils palier je pense qu'il faut
qu'on soit plus dans la co construction
alors je le gâteau continue à distribuer
la parole mais d'abord vous la donner à
vous chers internautes
car point de vue et votre émission
pierre nous dit héroux donc à eruh
cesser ce défenseur ou passeurs de
migrants a été condamné à plusieurs
reprises par la justice lui remettre une
médaille pour les faits qui lui ont valu
des condamnations revient à faire
l'apologie de crime délit puni par la
loi
christian pinaudeau dit le maire de
grenoble ferait mieux de s'occuper de la
délinquance qui subsistent dans sa ville
et nadia depuis nous dit le maire de
grenoble doit être condamné c'est la loi
en plus il était une politique donc il a
agi comme un délinquant vous êtes donc
assez sévère avec le maire de grenoble
ces vérités qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
pour l'instant dans la question twitter
évidemment ce n'est pas un sondage
puisque c'est sur la base du volontariat
en gros les deux tiers d'entre vous ne
soutiennent pas son sa décision de décor
et cédric et roudon qui a organisé le
passage de plusieurs migrants dans pour
passer la frontière française
benoît du moulin à votre avis sur ce
sujet paradoxalement moi je vais pas
forcément
surenchérir dans la condamnation en fait
vu distinguer deux choses il ya le le
principe dans l'absolu et le cas concret
dans principe moi je suis pas opposé à
ce que un maire un élu local qui est
censé appliquer la loi puisse dire je
j'encourage à violer la loi ou notre
principe supérieur parce que je pense
que trois canaux loi morale supérieure à
la loi civile
moi même j'ai fait partie de ceux qui en
2013 prôné dans un dans d'autres
circonstances de la blessure ont
conscience des mères qui refusait
d'appliquer la loi taubira et qui disait
comme le maire d'arcangues ou de
montfermeil banon pense que cette loi là
où des couples homosexuels exactement
mais alors ça c'est dans l'absolu donc
pour la désobéissance civile face à un
grand débat on pourra peut-être en
parler mais alors dans le cas concret
qui nous occupe
non enfin le je ne vois pas quel est le
principe moral supérieur qui qui qui
exigerait qu'ils retireraient que ce que
ce mr eric piolle soutiennent à l'action
de de gens comme ceux de cédric héroux
donc vous avez parlé faciliter le
passage de l'an 250 migrants avaient
pour ça est organisée de façon
effectivement il s'achète une massive
il s'achète une bonne conscience morale
sur le dos des migrants mais peut-être
qu'il est sincère
je ne nie pas la sincérité mais le
problème c'est que à un moment il ya des
faits il pourrait très bien s'occuper
des migrants qui sont déjà sur le sol
français qui est arrivé maintenant des
circonstances tout à fait légale et
pourquoi s'occuper d'en faire passer
d'autres sachant qu'en plus on fait le
fait de l'argent et le bénéfice des
passeurs alors si on est un peu
responsable quand on est citoyen on va
pas encourager toutes ces filières là on
sait très bien que il y en a un sur dix
qui arrive donc il ya neuf qui y
laissent leur vie en méditerranée et or
on envoie un signal à tous ces
trafiquants et ses marchands d'esclaves
dans la corne de l'afrique au maghreb
que en fait une allemands ils peuvent
très bien continuer puisque il ya des
gens qui sont des idiots utiles et qui
les aident à passer et
c'est vrai que c'est scandaleux dionne
demongeot moi je trouve que sur la forme
en effet c'est d'abord sur la forme le
tweet envoyé à tout le monde et au
préfet en dix ans condamnés mois s est
déjà c'est une façon de dire en fait
déjà je suis je suis déjà en train de
faire un coup de com donc on est on est
presque mais main de dieu nous mêmes
c'est réussir comme en parle mais oui
c'est déjà une réussite c'est raté pour
12 mai mais en effet il est officier de
la police judiciaire officiellement dès
lors qu'ils représentent l'ordre public
qui doit le défendre et je crois que je
crois qu'il a sur le fond vous avez tout
à fait raison il est dans un
encouragement à quelque chose d'une
dissidence et même si le logiciel
profonde ed d'europe écologie les verts
c'est toujours le droit de désobéir je
pense que ce même mère le jour où il
aurait été face à des mères objecteurs
de conscience qui est enfin qui aurait
refusé de marier des couples homosexuels
aurait donné son avis en disant c'est un
scandale il faut respecter la loi
il est censé l'appliquer de façon
extrêmement stricte
donc on est dans une espèce de logique
et en plus voilà williams toro et dit ce
qu'ils veulent vraiment désobéir mais
ils désobéissent et puis démissionne ils
vont en prison et je vois que ce mr mrs
mère est alors que voilà s'il est un
vrai problème avec la façon dont la
france ait légiféré ben on ne demande
pas du tout on n'oblige pas à rester
autre point d'actualité
les forces de l'ordre ont démantelé ce
matin un camp de plus de 1000 personnes
des migrants dans paris la maire de
paris anne hidalgo demande la
construction de deux lieux d'accueil
durable pour ces migrants est ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne idée
question ouverte oui je pense que c'est
une bonne idée parce que j'aimais l'idée
mais ce qui est étonnant c'est les choix
secteur qu'est là qu'elle a faits qui
sont des secteurs
enfin je crois qu'il était question à un
moment donné que ce soit dans le bois de
boulogne tout auprès d'un d'un quartier
complètement résidentiel de personnes
qui évidemment vont vont manifester une
clairvaux mauvaise volonté pour pas pour
intérieur que keaven paternel et qui ne
votent pas pour elle et qui par ailleurs
en plus ça pose un problème de bon sens
comment voulez vous allez acheter au
franprix vos yeux à 5 euros dans le
veiller en fait tout ce qui est ces
quartiers résidentiels sont conçus comme
un peu des endroits où tout est plus
cher parce que les gens là donc en fait
c'est un peu ridicule voilà c'est sur le
secteur mais moi je trouve que c'est du
très bonne idée de trouver après le
risque de former une forme d'appel d'air
puisque parce que on sait bien que les
migrants communiquent entre eux ils ont
des téléphones mobiles et donc en disant
que vous pouvez venir on est logés et un
problème général de l'ets de
l'immigration en europe il ya un sondage
yougov qui date d'il ya un mois dans 15
pays d'europe dans ses 15 pays d'europe
qu'elle est là le sujet d'interrogations
et de deux sujets de d'inquiétude
principal des deux de 13 pays sur 15
c'est l'immigration
si on veut d'autres votent comme celui
qui venait d'avoir lieu en italie comme
il y en a eu en autriche comme il ya
maintenant la pologne la hongrie et la
république tchèque
continuons la proche la prochaine vague
migratoire nous ne sommes absolument pas
prêts à l'affronter nos gouvernements
sont incapables de tenir les frontières
de l'europe
et si nous sommes réellement incapable
de tenir les frontières de l'europe
d'avoir une politique de migration
commune une politique du droit d'asile
commune avec des règles communes
eh bien nous allons être effectivement
dans une situation très grave parce que
des mouvements populistes elle que ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui en italie au
pouvoir nous allons les voir partout
donc il faut absolument arrêter de jouer
avec l'immigration d'en faire un sujet
de débat politique en interne parce que
c'est un sujet qui est très qui est
ressenti par le peuple les populations
européennes comme la preuve de la
faillite des institutions européennes
donc il faut arrêter de jouer avec ça
radiant d'animaux oui non
alors le problème de l'installation
deux des migrants enfin sur le
territoire français c'est un peu comme
les éoliennes c'est que tout le monde
est pour mais personne ne l'a vue près
de chez soi ça reste un peu compliqué
moi j'aimerais aussi qu'on s'attarde sur
la politique d'intégration des personnes
qui sont en situation régulière et là
aussi on a là on a un large public et
qui n'est pas totalement aborder les
gens n'ont pas le bon quota en terme de
cours de langue de langue française
c'est vrai on pourrait décliner pas mal
dit m sur ces questions là qu'il
faudrait renforcer avant de vouloir être
bienveillants vis-à-vis des autres et en
accueillir forcément de nouveaux on
passe à un autre suspect qui n'a rien à
voir le gouvernement ils réunis en
séminaire
aujourd'hui pour réfléchir aux façons de
faire des économies avec l'argent public
c'est un petit peu nécessaire puisque la
france est championne d'europe en
matière de dépenses publiques
56 4% du pib
ça veut dire qu'en gros quand il ya 100
euros de richesse qui se créé en france
il y en a cinquante six qui sont pour la
puissance publique l'état au sens large
parce qu'en fait très largement cette
dépense publique elle est le fait là de
la sécurité sociale qui représente plus
de près de 600 milliards d'euros de
dépense chaque année
toujours est il que emmanuel macron
s'est fixé des objectifs ambitieux et
100 milliards d'euros d'économies d'ici
pour l'instant ces économies on les voit
absolument pas venir en 2007 il y en a
pas eu
alors les économies c'est pour quand
écoutez ce qu'on pense damien abad
il est député de l'ain il est aussi vice
président des républicains et lui les
promesses gouvernementales
il n'y croit pas trop regarder sur la
question des dépenses publiques c'est le
grand flou artistique au sein du
gouvernement
le gouvernement joue avec le chaud et le
froid et la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
que on voit bien qu'il ya des désaccords
entre d et surtout aucun cap et aucune
décision qui est prise on a le sentiment
que c'est finalement les services
administratifs qui imposent leurs règles
au ministre qu'est ce que c'est bien la
priorité si on veut et que de faire des
économies dans la dépense publique
ou est-ce qu'il faut pas en faire parce
que finalement on a besoin de cet
amortisseur social
il ya un effet d'annonce et la réalité
ne suis pas sûr que macro multiplient
les annonces et finalement le
le budget va augmenter en 2010 8 par
rapport 2007 de 7,3 milliards d'euros
alors qu'elles sont les deux
lancera-t-elle compte exactement
alors quelles sont les priorités vous
l'avez rappelé bien sûr ce sont les
dépenses sociales mais aussi les
intérêts de la dette publique le plus
grand poste
et puis la défense d'éducation alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par rapport à
ça
déjà je crois que il ya un point sur
lequel il faudrait s'attaquer c'est les
la masse des personnels mac on veut
augmenter le je crois les le volume
horaire dans la fonction publique
territoriale c'est très bien mais il
faudrait déjà là dégraisser la fonction
publique territoriale entre 1992 et
aujourd'hui
elle a doublé ou triplé de volume après
concernant les fonctionnaires moi je ne
vois pas en quoi le maintien d'un statu
se justifie hormis cas exceptionnel dans
certains corps particulier de l'état
mais sinon on pourrait bien sûr beaucoup
plus embaucher des contractuels
ce qui veut dire piloter la masse
salariale de façon beaucoup plus simple
ensuite les dépenses sociales moi je
crois que un jour on sera obligé de
d'avoir un système un peu à la carte
c'est à dire de mettre ce supprimer le
monopole de la sécu et de la mettre non
pas de supprimer le service public de la
santé
mais de mettre en concurrence la sécu
avec d'autres organismes comme le
préconise certaines directives de
l'union européenne comme ça on fera
baisser les coûts et on augmentera on
favorisera une meilleure prise en charge
déjà si vous tapez dans ses lancers deux
dans ces deux domaines
vous réduisez pas mal ce dernier domaine
puisque ont parlé d'éducation là je
crois que pareille on ne pourra pas
tenir un système totalement centralisée
depuis la rue de grenelle on n'échappera
pas à une réforme de l'éducation par
divers systèmes mais qui ferait que qui
barrerait beaucoup d expériences locales
comme espérance banlieue ou autres qui
ne requiert pas d'argent de la puissance
publique
alors on vous pose la question selon
vous faut-il que le gouvernement réduise
de train de vie de l'état en question un
petit peu orienté peut-être mais après
tout elle est sur twitter et elle
s'assume comme tel 88%
nous répondent que oui il faut que le
gouvernement réduise le train de vie de
l'état
nos internautes ont des idées là-dessus
sur lefigaro.fr sur le sur twitter
hashtag figaro live achetés à coups de
batte cyr afin qu'il nous dit pour faire
des économies il faut tout d'abord
réformer les statuts des anciens
présidents
puis les anciens premiers ministres qui
coûte cher au contribuable et claudie
torregrossa qui est d'accord et qui dit
baisser les salaires et les avantages
des députés ministres sénateurs jon de
montjoux est-ce que vous avez des idées
vous pour faire pour dégraisser le
mammouth comme disait un peu crûment un
ancien ministre de l'éducation nationale
je suis pas très bonne en arithmétique
mais le dernier budget à l'équipe de la
france et 74 donc déjà macron il plus
jeune que la dette de la france et
chaque enfant qui naît aujourd'hui en
france a déjà 33 mille euros de dettes
sur les épaules à la sortie de la
maternité donc en fait il est
complètement absolument impensable de
maintenir ce train de vie complètement
d'airé qui déborde de partout etc
mais moi je fais que les cultes très
simple de l'année prochaine je suis
votre chiffre benoît de l'augmentation
de la dette publique avec la sncf en
2020 qui arrive nos 46 milliards d'euros
on réinjecte dans notre budget de l'état
et les 26 milliards d'euros qui sont
supprimés de la taxe d'habitation
ça nous fait déjà à une augmentation de
volume
où va-t-on trouver ci s'ils promettent
pas d'impôts en plus et où va-t-on
trouver cet argent donc à mon avis ça ne
peut que qu'augmenter mais je pense que
les modèles macron aime les effets d
annonce
en général ils essayent de faire de son
mieux pour pour essayer de rentrer dans
les bonnes directions des pas dans la
bonne dans laxe de ses promesses mais
jusqu'à maintenant il n'a pas mis assez
d'ampleur à son geste
et étant donné les bisbilles entre bruno
le maire et darmanin qui ont été déjà
aperçue récemment quand bruno le maire a
osé dire non il fallait changer aux
armadas à l'air d'accord pour dire que
parfois il ya des cachettes pour des
cachettes 2
de subventions ou de dette sociale qui
empêche les gens d'être motivés pour
reprendre un travail
on va dans la bonne ligne mais tout le
monde est très prudent on sent qu'on est
sur un terrain hyper miné et à mon avis
c'est typiquement le genre de réformes
qui vont être très douloureuse pour les
français et qui vont se traduire dans
les urnes et elles se font les trouver
les recettes dans vos paris il va les
trouver
malheureusement en sommes à part
l'augmentation de la csg sur les
retraités soit disant riche mais en fait
avec macro on est riche comme quand on a
un revenu fiscal de référence au dessus
de 14000 euros
et là c'est quand même une mesure qui
est insupportable et qui est d'ailleurs
très mal perçue par la population
brice couturier on peut dire que vous
avez général un regard plutôt
bienveillant sur la politique d'
emmanuel macron est ce aussi le cas sur
sa politique de réduction de la dépense
publique
moi j'attends de voir pour l'instant
vous avez rappelé les chiffres ils sont
terrifiants 56 4% du pib passe dans la
dépense publique en france contre 49 1 %
en suède et 43 9% en allemagne
comment se fait-il que l'état français
dépense tellement plus que l'état
suédois
on nous dit on a une politique sociale
très avancé très avantageuse pour les
français je suis désolé je connais pas
mal la suède dans la politique sociale
de la suède est bien plus avantageuses
pour les suédois quand se fait-il
qu'elle soit plus avantageuse et moins
cher ma conclusion c'est qu'on n'en a
pas pour notre argent dans ce pays
clairement les services publics sont pas
à la hauteur de ce qu'on paye pour eux
moi je prends le train tous les matins
en ce moment je souffre un enfer
aujourd'hui mois pour moi c'est pas la
souffrance au travail qui compte c'est
la souffrance dans les transports en
commun dont on parle très peu d'ailleurs
dans les médias il ya vraiment et puis
alors le rapport pisa montre la
dégradation régulière d'année en année
des résultats de nos institutions
scolaires universitaires aussi du reste
l'hôpital ne fonctionne plus il est à
peu près bloqué a essayé essayé d'aller
emmener votre enfant accessoires aux
urgences vous allez voir ce qui s'y
passe bref on paye très cher un service
public qui ne fonctionne pas pourquoi
pas d'une part parce que il ya une
tradition une tradition clientéliste des
gouvernements successifs qui sont
succédé chacun rajoutant une strate
supplémentaire de fonctionnaires
embauchés notamment et surtout il faut
le dire par les collectivités
territoriales parce que l'état lui a
fait des efforts
très insuffisant bien entendu non la
question si vous laissez la question de
l' architecture globale de la puissance
publique sait quels sont les domaines
d'intervention qui lui reviennent en
propre et ce qu'il devrait abandonner
il y en a beaucoup qui devrait
abandonner et puis il ya une autre
question qui paraît et bah quand vous
avez c'est vrai il est clair par exemple
que dans le domaine de l'éducation sheth
d'accord avec vous il devrait y avoir un
meilleur partage en angleterre et en
suède en suède il ya trois systèmes
éducatifs possibles dont un qui est
entièrement pris en charge à
l'initiative des parents d'élèves eux
mêmes
j'évolue cru avec un chèque éducation
donnée par l'état et ses institutions
suédois marche beaucoup mieux en jalles
que ceux du public
il ya beaucoup et puis attendez il ya un
autre truc que je voudrais dire quand
même ces deux numérique dans dans le
privé dans le privé le numérique a été
un facteur formidable d'alimentation des
productivités d'où d'ailleurs apprennent
de chômage parce que dans beaucoup la
plupart des entreprises ont fait on
produit davantage avec moins de
personnel désarmant quand c'est le cas
de l'état lui le numérique n'a donné
aucune augmentation de la productivité
et au contraire des rajouts de fonctions
supplémentaires
il ya vraiment un problème de fond alors
que l'administration devraient être
numérisés comme elle l'est en estonie
surtout qu'elle peut l'être quand elle
veut vous savez un certain nombre
j'imagine est en train de faire de
déclaration de revenu sur sur internet
est en ligne
et quand il s'agit de récupérer l'argent
du contribuable ça marche très très bien
reda didi vous est probablement le seul
d'entre nous ici à avoir vu de
l'intérieur l'appareil d'état je le
disais vous avez été conseiller d'un
ministre sous le quinquennat précédent
c'est toujours difficile quand on arrive
concrètement à dire où est ce qu'on
trouve les économies c'est toujours chez
les autres il faut les trouver un point
de méthodologie on dit pourquoi en
france on n'arrive pas finalement faire
des économies
je pense qu'il ya dix à trois raisons
fondamentales à ça la première c'est
qu'on a des élections assez fréquentes
en france et qu'on a l'habitude est plus
distribué que de vouloir donner une
vision où on va on redouble aisément que
les élections c'est moi et voilà c'est
un peu non mais il ya quelque chose à
regarder
de ce point de vue là la seconde c'est
que je pense qu'on n'a pas assez de
structures intermédiaires qui sont en
capacité de faire de la co-construction
d'accompagner les réformes d'expliquer
de faire de la pédagogie sur pourquoi il
faudrait réduire nos dépenses à tort ou
à raison d'ailleurs
datchy pas encore répondu j'aimerais à
la fin et enfin le troisième point c'est
que je pense que dans la tête de la
majorité des français ça fait 30 ans
qu'ils font des économies qui font des
efforts les français en fait et qu'on
leur demande de faire des efforts qu'on
rallonge le temps de retraite qu'on
augmente les impôts pendant crée de
nouveau et donc que ça donne pas tant le
résultat est qu'on va encore leur
demander des efforts donc là il ya
encore un point à à retravailler
j'aimerais dire deux choses je pense que
là où on peut faire des économies c'est
que au niveau des des structures
représentatives
on a un problème nous on a faim de
niveau de représentation alors que dans
les pays en allemagne ou en suède on est
à trois matches l'amical donc on a les
villes on a les intercommunalités on a
les départements on a les régions et en
à l'état là il y en a là on voit bien
qu'il ya un point sur lequel on peut
faire
des économies et d'autres points ont été
évoqués je ne mets juste le doigt sur un
point - l'éducation la rendre plus
performante
voilà je l'entends il met moins de
moyens je suis pas sûr comme dirait
jefferson
si vous pensez que l'éducation coûte
cher essayez l'ignorance ou pour ceux
qui veulent la rendre autonome vous
parler de ses expériences d'espérance
banlieue je renvoie au portrait que
dionne de mon jouet a fait dans le
figaro du du créateur de cette fondation
quelques points de vue des internautes
d'abord le dr sheldon qui tout à fait
d'accord avec vous reda didi qui dit il
ya des économies à faire sans que ça
coûte un centime au peuple de france
alors lui il veut supprimer le sénat et
le conseil économique social et
environnemental sur lefigaro.fr altaï
cas nous dit il faudrait pouvoir virer
un fonctionnaire lorsqu'il est mauvais
ou ne pas lui donner d'augmentation du
tout tandis que jean loup robert nous
dit on commence par baisser les aides
après peut-être s'intéresseront nous
nous intéresserons aux j'imagine au
nombre de fonctionnaires dans certaines
collectivités et betsy raffin nous dit
quelque chose qui me paraît plein de bon
sens nous avons toujours le même
discours mais pas d'action et ceci avec
tous les gouvernements il ya un argument
classique qui consiste à dire la france
n'est pas en assez bon état pour pouvoir
faire des économies c'est à dire qu'en
gros comme il ya beaucoup de croissance
le les aides sociales c'est un
amortisseur à la crise brice couturier
vous êtes convaincus par s'arrêter c'est
un cercle vicieux
on nous dit comme l'économie est
atrophié par le poil des prélèvements
obligatoires du coup il n'y a pas
d'emploi comme il n'y a pas d'emploi il
faut plus d aides sociales etc
il ya un moment et je pense que bakr on
est dans cette logique là la logique de
macron cdh a dédié on arrête cirque on
arrête on essaie d'arrêter d'étouffer
l'économie on lui rend son dynamisme et
ainsi nous aurons moins besoin d'une
aide sociale car en effet c'est pas les
fonctionnaires le problème de la de
déficits publics et de et de la dépense
publique le problème de la dépense
publique c'est la politique sociale là
encore nous nous sommes les meilleurs au
monde on a fait 30 2% du pib pour la
dépense sociale c'est extravagant les
suédois sont très très loin de ça
simplement ils sont loin de ça non pas
parce qu'ils sont moins généreux à
l'égard des des gens
mais c'est simplement parce qu'il ya
moins de chômage quand vous êtes quand
vous entretenez un chômage de masse
pendant des années et que vous atrophiée
site est maintenant qu'on vous étouffer
l'économie par le poids des prélèvements
obligatoires
inévitablement vous avez à faire face à
une demande de dette sociale
extravagantes et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui donc la solution c'est de
relancer l'économie de faire en sorte
que le chômage structurel
au lieu de se trouver à des taux
extravagant redevienne disons comme
celui des allemands autour de 4% et non
pas de 10 ou 12 et à ce moment là on
aura beaucoup moins besoin de dépenses
sociales on laisse le dernier mot sur ce
sujet si vous le voulez bien à alixan
dauphine qui nous dit pendant ce temps
là les députés réfléchissent à savoir si
on doit dire chocolatines ou pains au
chocolat c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un
amendement en ce sens pour une un projet
de loi récents je crois sur la sécurité
alimentaire
qu'ils soient payés au smic et on verra
après s'il ne voit pas des choses
différemment
écoutez voilà un projet ambitieux
passons à un autre thème si vous le
voulez bien à la laïcité jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a supervisé la réalisation et
la publication d'un guide de la laïcité
à l'attention du corps enseignant alors
il ya beaucoup de mesures qui sont
extrêmement concrètes dans ce dans ce
guide je vous en cite quelques unes en
vrac je les tire de du très bon papier
est fait par mark estelle pech sur
lefigaro.fr
alors il ne sera plus possible de
refuser
il y aura des sanctions fortes pour les
élèves qui refusent d activité
obligatoire pour des raisons religieuses
qu'il s'agisse d'activités sportives ou
de certains cours ou certaines visites
le une des élèves qui ont des tenues qui
ne soit pas ouvertement religieuse mais
qui ont une connotation religieuse par
exemple une jupe longue de couleur
sombre ainsi qu un bandana couvrant
partiellement la chevelure tout ça est
extrêmement concret pourra être
sanctionné en revanche les mères de
familles qui accompagnent des sorties
scolaires pourront porter le voile ça
n'est pas nouveau puisque c'est najat
vallaud belkacem qui avait pris cette
décision alors qu'auparavant cela leur
était interdit au nom de la neutralité
du service public
et puis pour noël on aura droit de
mettre des sapins dans les classes mais
pas de père noël ni encore moins de
crèches alors est ce que blanc caire en
fait trop ou est-ce que cette est-ce que
ce projet était et équilibrée reda didi
vous avez eu le temps de
d'en prendre connaissance j'ai regardé
façon transversale
d'abord moi je salue le travail qui est
fait par jean michel blanc pierre il n'y
a pas un mot qui me gêne dans les propos
qui ont qui ont pu être tenus le conseil
des sages
je trouve ça très intéressant j'y ai des
amis le vade-mecum sur la laïcité le
trouve intéressant il faut que j'ai pas
dû le le contenu mais il me semble que
là il répond à une attente c'est à dire
que les enseignants ont besoin d'avoir
un outil sur lequel s'appuyer pour
pouvoir traiter de cette question et en
plus ont besoin de pouvoir échanger sur
cette question là avec d'autres ont
besoin ne pas être seul et isolé toute
évidence j ajouterai peut-être une
formation où moi je vais beaucoup
d'éducation populaire j'ai été directeur
de centre de vacances et animateur en
centre de vacance est ce qu'on apprend
aux animateurs fait d'avoir du bon sens
en fait dire qu'il n'ya pas de situation
on peut avoir un vade-mecum qui explique
toutes les situations et sur lesquelles
on va trouver une solution
donc faut avoir du bon sens en ayant un
concept clair dans sa tête de ce qu'est
la laïcité voilà g20 que c'est
problématique là puissent être travaillé
à un moment de
deux formations si j'avais un seul point
sur lequel que je discuterai c'est cette
idée il prend un exemple dans son
interview fleuve à l'express où il dit
un gamin qui dit allah ouakbar en
sixième ne peut et ne doit pas rester
sans réaction
j'étais surveillants mois pour payer mes
études au collège des sixièmes et les
cinquièmes c'est quand même la joue on
est un peu en révolte on dit un peu
n'importe quoi où on fait tout pour se
faire remarquer je veux dire qu'il ait
pas de réaction c'est une chose on doit
réagir un peu fou qui ne la rendra tout
proportionnée faut pas tout sur
interpréter et à un enfant les besoins
d'un mollet besoin de l'adolescent sont
aussi à à prendre en compte si on veut
pas y mettre un message politique mais
où un autre message là où il y en a pas
là où c'est juste une envie de se faire
remarquer au jeu de rejet de sa classe
votre point de vue sur ce sur ce guide
ou en tout cas ces principes
plusieurs choses déjà une c'est vrai que
le ministre donne des orientations qui
auront l'air enfin qu'il faut
l'impression qu'il fait preuve de
fermeté et on peut que saluer les
mesures qui qu'il détaille maintenant
j'ai une crainte voire deux la première
c'est que il faut avoir avec le temps
qu'il s'agit d'un effet d'annonce il ya
eu plein déjà plusieurs plans de de
lutte pour contre pour le respect des
principes posés à l'école est-ce que ils
vont réellement être appliqué serait ce
que la hiérarchie du ministère de
l'éducation nationale va soutenir les
profs qui se plaignent qu'ils disent non
mais là je ne peux pas faire court je
peux pas enseigner telle matière parce
qu'on me dit maintenant dans le coran
vous vous n'avez pas le droit
d'enseigner vous êtes prof laïque
voilà est-ce que est-ce qu'on va avoir
vraiment une hiérarchie qui va suivre
puisque les profs se plaignent beaucoup
de ça c'est aussi un rapport de force
qui est parfois exactement notamment
dans dans certaines écoles ou bas par
exemple moi j'ai vu ça en période de
ramadan bien il ya plus personne alors
vous avez vous avez beau dire tous les
élèves qui sont pas là sont punis bas si
personne ne vient même temps là le
problème des sanctions c'est très bien
d'avoir la firme et des grands principes
mais fremm des sanctions c'est que il
faut que quand vous les annonces et vous
puissiez les rendre effectives et là il
ya dans certains dans certaines zones
basses et on va voir comment ça va se
passer
premièrement et 2,6
une petite gêne c'est que tous ait
affirmé sous la houlette du principe de
laïcité
alors je veux bien mais moi j'ai un
petit souci c'est que à chaque fois on
se drape chaussures en englobant toutes
les religions alors qu'on sait qu'à
l'école les problèmes sont posés par la
ridley radicalisation de certaines
familles et ça vient de l'islamisme
radical
alors j'aimerais que l'on puisse ne pas
englober dans dans le mot laïc qui est
facile mais tout les toutes les
religions et puis et dire maintenant le
problème c'est un régal et même
peut-être même pas religieux c'est celui
du communautarisme communautarisme il
est instrumentalisé peut-être à des fins
religieuses mais en tout cas c'est une
ségrégation des de gens qui veulent
faire sécession avec nos moeurs notre
mode de vie par un code vestimentaire
par le refus de certains cours
d'histoire par la voix là et qu'on dise
des choses clairement parce que sinon on
va entretenir l'idée que s'en fait
ah ben oui c'est le fait religieux qui
pose problème et donc il faut rajouter
un coup de laïcité
et là je crois qu'on irait dans une
impasse je sens plus côtoyé à peu en
désaccord sur ce point
si vous voulez moi je vois pas pourquoi
on ferait
discriminations qu'elles soient
positives ou négatives à l'égard de
telle ou telle religion la plus grande
françois fillon avait eu cette sortie un
peu courte mais qui avait l'avantagé
d'être clair
en tout cas dans son esprit la france
n'a pas un problème avec les religions
la france a un problème avec l'islam
bah pas seulement il ya des intégristes
aussi plutôt déplaisant de du côté
d'autres religions déjà quand vous
parlez de gens qui font sécession
il ya aussi des chrétiens intégristes
qui font session dans notre qui font
sécession dans notre pays pour l'instant
il étrangle personnes vous me direz
c'est une bonne chose
il n'ya pas d'attentats protestants tant
mieux mais enfin je les services à
l'école où ils peuvent avoir des
exigences très particulière qui eux
aussi sont une gêne pour le
fonctionnement de régulier des services
publics
nancy voulait moi moi je soutiens tout à
fait blancs caire à fond je remarque
c'est d'ailleurs une belle une belle
vitrine pour la macro ni de manière
générale il fait 58% d'opinions
favorables ce qui dans l'état actuel de
l'opinion
très remonté contre les politiques de
manière générale est un très beau score
bravo effectivement il est sympa ouvert
tolérant dépourvu d'idéologie
pragmatique c'est vraiment l'image
l'image idéale de la macro n'y on
aimerait que tous les ministres soient
sont à son image
et puis par ailleurs sur la laïcité il
ya un problème on sait bien qu'il ya un
problème du côté de la macro ni là
encore c'est qu'il ya deux tendances
ce que dit très bien à l'inter ouvertes
du figure de l'express d'ailleurs dans
l'interview fleuve dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure on sait bien concerne ma
chronique vous avez un courant disons
pour une laïcité ouverte et blanc caire
qui lui pour une laïcité sans adjectif
comédie c'est à dire sans qualificatif
l'adversité points point barre et moi
c'est celle qui me satisfait parce que
ce que je remarque surtout et c'était
très bien dit c'est que les professeurs
j'ai deux chiens ancien prof m'a les
professeurs et ont été longtemps
abandonné véritablement par le ver archi
avec avec le le principe et le mode
horde pas de vagues
pas de vague donc quand il y avait un
problème quelque part on abandonnait les
profs on les a vraiment abandonné il ya
des collègues des amis encore qu' on
était vraiment dans des situations
dangereuses dans des dents certains
établissements abandonnés par leur
hiérarchie sur le thème ne fait pas de
vagues
là il ya un référence il y aura un
référent au ministère
chaque professeur qui rencontrent un
problème sérieux aura une réponse dans
les 24 heures assurances du ministre
donc si vous voulez il pourra passer par
dessus sa hiérarchie et c'est ça qui
compte par dessus son proviseur par
dessus son recteur d'académie
si besoin est et peut-être qu'on les
changera aussi diane demongeot
mais cette cette laïcité sans adjectif
moi me questionne parce que en fait
cette question religieuse elle elle et
elle est de plus en plus présente dans
l'école d'aujourd'hui dans ces collèges
hyper volumineux avec trop d'élèves pas
assez d'encadrement et c est donc elle
devient vous disiez un rapport de force
mais elle elle est vraiment très
présente et jusqu'à maintenant j'ai
l'impression que les professeurs étaient
assez démuni devant cette question et
donc je préfère voilà la vision de manal
macron qui est pas la même que celle de
blanc caire qui est plus libérale où il
ne nie pas la présence du car est de la
question religieuse delà de la soif de
réponse à ce niveau là et en même temps
reste extrêmement vigilant à ce que tout
ça puisse cohabiter et dialoguer
ensemble donc ce soit nommé parce que
j'ai l'impression que la république
laïque telle qu'elle a été pensée
jusqu'à à peu près aujourd'hui soit été
le déni total donc on ne parle pas là
qu'ils auraient josé évacué hors de ses
murs elle apparaît n'a pas existé ça
soit justement quand il y avait un
surgissement en violant le voile d'un
seul coup des élèves qui imposait
consensuel ramadan ou je sais pas quoi
ou que la piscine soit interdite aux
jeunes filles ou qui est des contrats d
des ordonnances de complaisance de
médecins pour éviter qu'elles puissent
se mettre en maillot de bain ou chez
papa et bien là on a on avait on était
complètement démunis donc ses 83 pages
elles ont le mérite
les 83 pages distribué aux professeurs
ont le mérite en effet de donner une
espèce de d'appui aux professeurs mais
par ailleurs je trouve que en fait blanc
caire en disant lui qu'il est favorable
à une
une laïcité sans adjectif lui il donne
des gages à la gauche pour faire passer
la pilule de la discipline qui est une
pilule un peu difficile à faire passer
par certains pour certains syndicats
très progressiste mais par ailleurs je
ne crois que derrière il ya une petite
voix qui est quand même celle de macron
et peut-être de certains autres
ministres qui est plus favorable à une
maille cité souple il parlait aux
bernardins peut-être judaïcité plus plus
ouverte à la question religieuse qu'elle
soit peut-être présente nommé et
potentiellement camper quand même dans
le débat il ya toutes les nuances de la
laïcité qui s'inscrivent sur ce point
sur ce plateau et c'est très bien comme
ça on vous a posé la question c'est la
question du jour sur lefigaro.fr sur un
point très précis êtes vous favorable à
ce que des mères accompagnant tu puisses
être voilée à concept assez massivement
non 90%
comme toujours je précise que c'est là
sur la base de la du volontariat qui ne
s'agit pas d'un sondage les il nous
reste un peu de temps non je voulais
vous poser une autre question sur 7 sur
7 car oui et sur les sapins de noël un
sapin de noël oui à père noël non est ce
que vous trouvez que là on va à trois
doigts brice couturier est ce que votre
vision de la laïcité stricte va jusqu'à
vouloir interdire les perdants c'est
marrant parce que le père noël n'est pas
spécialement catholique c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont battus par les catholiques en
disant que c'était pas bien donc oui je
vois pas pourquoi on devrait supprimer
les au contraire ça me choque beaucoup
qu'on puisse celle là là on a un
affrontement véritablement avec des
islamistes intégristes j'ai vu en suède
par exemple un sapin de noël dévastés
dans un grand magasin par des
intégristes musulmans qui était fou
qu'on célèbre noël
et ben voilà dans ce pays on célèbre
noël pas parce que c'est une fête
religieuse à vrai dire mais c'est parce
que c'est l'occasion de faire des
cadeaux à ses enfants comme aux célèbres
pack aussi en donnant des oeufs
ça n'a rien à voir avec
telle ou telle croyance c'est juste
c'est juste des traditions locales en
plus en plus quand on connaît l'origine
exacte de ces fêtes on se consacrait ses
deux les catholiques les ont annexé pour
essayer de les justifier mais qu'en fait
elles viennent du paganisme le plus
ancien mais pour le sapin risque a vu sa
passe est très bon mais par contre qu'on
intègre
peut-être qu'on intègre aussi d'autres
fêtes musulmanes ou juives dans dans
notre dans nos traditions se serait pas
une mauvaise chose non plus ça ferait ça
ferait d'autres occasions de se réjouir
de manière collective et de travailler
moi peut-être que les élèves jouera la
fille d'un jour de congé supplémentaire
réside et c'est ce que je vous disais
que c'est une question de bon sens c'est
dire si on a un effet un enseignant qui
est équilibré qui explique
voilà une nouvelle fois ci les
traditions va passer de mes traditions
moi j'ai toujours grandi avec ça ça me
plaît ça me dire je trouve que
globalement le pays perd cette tradition
de noël moi je vois moins de décoration
que quand j'étais tout petit parfum dans
le pays que ce soit à moi ou à paris et
qui en même temps peut mettre en lumière
les traditions des uns et des autres qui
sont dans la classe a des points à des
moments tu es moi ça ne me gêne pas
revenir juste sur un plan qui a été
évoqué tout à l'heure je pense que aussi
l'un des problèmes de la question de
laïcité c'est la ghettoïsation de
certains de nos territoires ou en fait
il ya trop d'entre eux soit on est trop
enfermés ou finalement cette notion de
laïcité ne vit plus parce qu'on a une
majorité qui est différente delà de ce
qui est de ce qui est de 2 ce qui est la
france en fait qui peut faire fuir les
autres ça c'est un problème mais surtout
qui n'a pas de deux d'éléments fiables
et solides de ce qu'est vraiment la
notion de laïcité et de ce qui est
vraiment cette notion pour notre pour
notre pays
et là il ya une vraie politique à mener
de casser de caf de ces de ces critiques
étaient là pour arriver à une laïcité
plus juste quelques émissions points
quelques actions internautes pour finir
sur ce sujet en forme de plébiscite pour
jean michel blanquer blanquet le
meilleur ministre de l'éducation
nationale depuis des décennies nous dit
dr sheldon à l'examen dauphine encore
elle nous dit blanc caire est le seul
ministre digestion dans le gouvernement
tandis que catherine funfrock nous dit
je pense que monsieur blanquart fait
très bien qu'il continue
eh bien il sera sûrement ravis de ces
encouragements s'il est en train de
regarder
vue c'est très possible et nous on va
parler des droits du foot
alors je vous la fait courte vous n'êtes
pas des spécialistes les droits de
rediffusion à la télévision de la ligue
1 donc l'élite du football français ont
été remis aux enchères pour la période
2020 2024 et c'est un opérateur espagnol
qui en a fait l'acquisition pour plus
d'un milliard d'euros par an c'est 60%
de plus que les tarifs actuels ceux qui
étaient ceux qui avaient été déboursée
par bil in sports et par canal+ et
canal+ et ben il n'a pas pu suivre
regarder ce que disait ce matin sur
europe 1 maxime saada c'est le patron de
canal c'était impossible pour nous de
mise et de telles sommes et d'ailleurs
je crois que c'est impossible pour un
quelconque acteurs de mise et elles
soient maîtrisés
j'estime qu'ils sont payés un peu près
800 à 850 millions d'euros pour les
droits qu'ils ont acquis pour
rentabiliser ça il faudrait un peu près
7 millions d'abonnés à 15 euros par mois
pour rentabiliser cette somme
bein sport ça fait six ans qu'ils sont
là ils ont beaucoup plus de droits
qu'elle est bien la coupe du monde
l'euro toutes les compétitions
européennes ou presque le basket et
cetera et cetera
ils ont ils sont à peine arrivé à trois
millions et demi en fait il ya deux
points il ya les doutes sur la viabilité
de cet accord surtout que l'opérateur
espagnol est encore inconnu en france il
n'a pas encore sa chaîne
et puis sur le principe à ce que est ce
que tout ça c'est trop d'argent benoît
du moulin c'est les sommes en jeu qui me
paraissent monstrueuse
au regard de l'objectif assurer la
retransmission alors en fait moi je suis
pas du tout un spécialiste du foot
bien que le dossier du mois de l'ain
correct soit sur le foot mais sur un
angle bien particulier c'est à dire le
foot tant qu'enjeu économique politique
social voilà mais en fait moi ça me je
pense que ça met le doigt sur un
phénomène qui est une certaine forme de
grégarisation c'est à dire que on a
l'impression que c'est un peu du pain et
des jeux comme sous la rome antique où
finalement il ya certaines
appauvrissement culturel
moi j'aimerais bien alors c'est
peut-être un peu utopique mais qu'on se
presse dans les bibliothèques et qui est
que qu'on emprunte des livres quand ce
qu'on se dispute les grands classiques
en russie j'avais trouvé ça magnifique
il y avait enfin magnifique et
dramatique en même temps il y avait deux
il ya une rixe dans la rue et de risque
et de russes qui s'étaient battus très
fortement parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
d'accord sur l'interprétation de quand
tu vois la presse comme ça alors je dis
pas qu'il faut ce bal semer mais c'est
très réussi mais mais en même temps je
trouve ça bien le canton peut faire
vivre un certain débat intellectuel et
qu'on peut alors non et là on en est
très loin et donc c'est bon je sais vous
ennuie pas que je cite un autre journal
que le figaro dans l'opinion cet après
midi ils ont mis en ligne un papier sur
ce sujet qui me paraît extrêmement
intéressant et très inquiétant il montre
que derrière ces enjeux en fait il ya
des sommes yade et il ya des groupes
espagnols qui ont des intérêts bizarre
notamment ce groupe espagnol en question
et apparemment il a été racheté en
partie par la chine que enfermez-le
médias proches voilà mediapro raouraoua
euro reste je sais pas si je prononce
bien le patron ou un des patrons de ce
groupe est un trotskiste milliardaire
qui finance les indépendantistes
catalans donc il est lisse en gamme qui
est derrière tout ça j'aime bien ce que
disait le directeur de canal à l'instant
sur votre antenne
il est clair qu'il ya des d'autre enjeu
que directement sportif ou financier
derrière de notamment des enjeux
politiques
donc tout ça sent pas très bon
manifestement il s'est passé un an de
rentabiliser un investissement
il s'agit d'argent d'argent peut-être
pas très propres ailes à dire un mot
là-dessus
si vous le souhaitez je trouve qu'on est
loin du football que j'ai connu à dire
autour
voilà du camembert un camembert de la
merguez de la cre à bord mais avec des
copains je veux dire chercher je ne
pense pas qu'on soit dans cette image du
jeu et du pari des jeux en fait c'est
que je pense que ça veut dire tellement
inaccessible que on a de moins en moins
de monde qu'il est qui les regarde a
dépassé par manque de moyens de
milliards investis dans des petits
stades deux provinces où il ya du lien
social et on aimerait bien comprendre
pourquoi
d'un seul coup et c'est ces sommes en
fait on pas mises au service de quelque
chose de plus grand que cette entreprise
de déréalisation on est derrière sa télé
avec sa pizza commandes et on n'a aucun
voilà on regarde ce match hors de prix
on aura des figurants qui joueront le
jeu de d'un match de foot et tout sera
tout sera dé réaliser complètement parce
que ce sera devenu tellement incroyable
le montant des malades de ses budgets de
rigueur de fric le twittos swift sont
assez d'accord avec vous puisque c'est
la dernière question twitter de
l'émission selon vous les droits de
diffusion de la ligue 1 de football
valti leur estimation de 1 15 milliard
d'euros par an est bien à 71% d'entre
vous répondent non il semblerait que ce
soit aussi l'avis des participants à
cette émission on fait aujourd'hui un
anniversaire c'est les 50 ans de la
manifestation du 30 mai 68 où le peuple
gaulliste avait-on dit à l'époque
alors il n'y avait pas
y'avait pas le cabinet occurrence à
l'époque pour compter les manifestants
conduisait entre 500 mille et un million
étaient descendus dans la rue voilà une
question toute sa place que vous seriez
descendus dans la rue le 30 mai 68 brice
couturier
je suis désolé j'étais de l'autre côté
la cgt mais j'étais l'autre côté de la
barricade
non là bas j'ai l'âge d'avoir été sur
les barricades enfin pas papa activement
médias voire d'y avoir été tant
qu'observateur impliqués
si vous n'avez le truc c'est que
aujourd'hui on a célébré sur beaucoup de
médias beaucoup d'antennes
l'anniversaire de 68 en oubliant
toujours cette fin 68 cm chez les
gaullistes qui était de les plus
nombreux et que deux ils ont gagné les
élections a fait couture on a célébré
sur beaucoup d'antennes l'anniversaire
de mai 68 du côté des barricades pas de
l'autre côté et finalement c'est ce côté
là qu'à gagner on devrait tous ceux qui
voulaient une ride rééditer mai 68 c'est
à bien des jours devraient méditer sur
la façon dont ça s'est terminé
et ben voilà on le fait ici aujourd'hui
grâce à vous reda didi rien pu faire je
télécharge aura été d'une dot est de
l'autre côté avec benoît demoulins je
vous dis que peut-être on en rit un
candidat ben non justement moi je
défilais le 30 mai 68 ça aurait été un
peu remercier de gaulle pour sa gestion
des événements
moi je pense que ça fuite à baden baden
et calamiteuse que il est en partie
responsable d'une situation qui l'a pas
vu se développer durant les années 60 et
qui lui revient en boomerang en mai 68
que celui qui gère bien la crise et
pompidou quai aux affaires et qui est le
vrai artisan du de cette vague bleue et
de la chambre introuvable de mai 68 et
donc je vois pas pourquoi je serais
descendu je n'étais pas né bien sûr mais
serait descendu pour remercier de gaulle
en quoi que ce soit de mon jouet ouvert
trouver en vous la manifestante qui me
manque ce soir
je dirais que je n'arriverai pas à
répondre personnellement de christian
mai mais en revanche je me rappelle que
jean sévillia roulement de notre numéro
spécial dans le figaro magazine sur mai
68 a dit à la fin en fait la politique à
gagner enfin le parti de gaulle a gagné
les conservateurs ont repensé morceau
grâce à notamment cette manifestation
qui était une démonstration de force
mais en fait mai 68 les barricades ont
gagné parce qu'ils ont infiltré tous les
médias tous les tous les services de
publicité et donc c'est eux qui ont
finalement gagné la vraie partie qui
était de la partie symbolique
intellectuelle etc
et c'est aujourd'hui leurs idées qui ont
qui ont prévalu et bien sûr cette
réponse très corporate puisque vous
essayez emmagasine excellente
publication au demeurant cette édition
s'achève merci beaucoup de l'avoir suivi
merci à tous les quatre et à demain même
heure même endroit pour un autre point
de vue bonsoir
[Musique]